they don't oh good I don't know how are
you awesome I'm good good yeah here at
home with my PJs I'm good I'm
uncomfortable then in the normal sort of
junket scenario huh I love this this is
cozy
I don't problem with this new reality
it's making us do things that you know
we're obviously not used to but it's
very easy to get used to this one yeah
you're you're very much a family man you
must have been enjoying your time at
home with the kids huh I do I I it's
it's been beautiful my mom spent the
quarantine here with us and and then
were were a lot and we're loud and we're
Latino so yeah there's no time for satin
is there's no time for it we just gotta
be there available for the kids and and
for each other it's been very
interesting like for all of us but I I
now see light at the end of the tunnel
so it's been that's yeah I think at the
beginning of this obviously it was a big
adjustment for everybody and your plans
for 2020 had to be turned upside down
and you know pause as a result of that
right true true yes my I was on the road
my tour was called movimiento which
means movement and and the album was
also gonna be called movement there is a
really nice song called movement so I
had to had to divide them between volume
1 and volume 2 and and separate the more
introspective sounds ballads and mid
temples for now because it's where we
are is it's exactly where I'm at and and
when I released
I was pause the the reaction of the of
the of the audience of the media was
like thank you so much you've you've
brought you've created the soundtrack of
our lockdown and so well it's people are
receiving it with with love and my
brother told me the other day I pressed
play at 6 a.m. in the morning and my day
has been so peaceful yeah that's what I
wanted to hear that what was what went
into that decision to say you know what
this we are gonna take this selection of
songs and cater it to this moment
it didn't make sense I mean I don't know
if you see my my concerts I I try to
really create Latin sounds Caribbean
sounds I could try to create that few
and it doesn't matter what part of the
world you go to people love the
Caribbean sounds just takes them to this
vacation kind of mode mentally and and
and it's an it's liberating it's
cathartic I need it I need it it's it
runs in my veins so I I I said let's
just divide them let's let's think out
of the box is there a box where's the
box
who left the box but I think it's
important I think it's important to just
try new things and and and the record
company was like what do you like what
are we ok let's give it a try and I
think it makes sense it's relevant the
the what I'm talking about in the music
that I'm presenting at the moment it's
it's about emotions that I wrote maybe 9
months ago but they're super relevant
and and then and then September October
will bring the party again hopefully and
speaking of you know trying new things
you think you made a point on this to
partner with musicians you haven't
worked with before before right yeah
those are pretty much our just reaching
out and asking how you how are you guys
swimming in the beginning of the
lockdown are you are you feeling as
crazy as I'm feeling because I'm going
crazy
hey everybody was a rig you know we're
giving the same and I love okay let's do
music let's get it out let's let's just
feel let's that's to make a long story
short
two days later I wasn't I was in the
studio with sting I mean he was in
London and I was here in Los Angeles but
but we created but we finished simple
and the same thing with Carla Morris and
she's from Mexico but she lives in Paris
and it was like what what are you
feeling let's do music and then recuerdo
the first single of this EP comes out
it's we're taking it one minute at a
time this you are not allowed to make
plans so right now living the moment
that concept that whatever
everybody talks about it's it's
something that we apparently have six
series has it been easier to come up
with music the idea that you know over
the course of two days you and Stan come
up with simply right
that would have been able to happen in
the regular cycle well I don't want to
say that it's in two days the song was
ready I started writing simply like
eight nine months ago so we've been
working but but the lyrics are so
relevant I sent them to him and he just
said can you at this and get rid of this
and and I'm ready to record so that's
that's what actually took two two days
there it was also a need to let go of
whatever we were feeling and that and
definitely that pressure makes things
flow and hmm and and and definitely the
pandemic made me finish my album it's
all it's all new man it's only just
better how how you try to bring codes of
the pre choral and an attitude into this
it just doesn't work and bang we have to
try new things your your music your
writing is always a reflection of what's
happening and it's apparent that it's a
reflection of what you're feeling to be
honest right has has a layers of meaning
can you tell us about that song where
the ideas came from well that song was
sent to me like two years ago and I
recorded it I said whenever I release
the album I want this out this song to
be part of the of the album because it's
it's about the vulnerability of a man
saying like hey I this we're breaking up
and just we shouldn't we should fight
for this let's talk about love Oh chasm
oh let's go out for a walk let's go to
the movies again like we used to it's
very romantic song but the video changes
the video it's not what you're expecting
the video is about this woman is very
confrontational it's about this woman
who stands in front of a variety lease
she looks at him in the eye and he goes
come on what are you doing and we see
the policeman taking his helmet off and
then though everybody take taking their
helmets off and then we celebrate this
was born of a very powerful protest two
years ago in Puerto Rico where more than
a million people went out in the streets
and we we got rid of our governor uh
which which i think exactly what needs
to happen here in America but it worked
for us in Puerto Rico it worked because
we only had one mission 1 million more
than 1 million people weren't went out
to the streets to let the world know
that this guy who was like a tyrant and
and that's where the the that's where
the what the video where the video comes
from and people just buy the video and
I'm I'm glad and and and that's that's
what art is about yeah well I mean
you're in America and around the world
that scene that you're describing of
someone going up against the authorities
is what's happening everywhere are you
hoping that with the movement that we're
seeing right now and that the momentum
that people have towards change will be
able to get there I mean obviously
you're hoping that we'll be able to get
there but what do you want to see what
you want to see when we get there i I
see I want to see what's happening know
people people afraid to change I want to
see people also willing to change I want
to see people thinking that they know
when they realize they don't know they
know nothing about racism in this case
and all this is happening I am I'm only
giving my social media to those
incredibly powerful voices that are
teaching me about everything that we've
been dealing with in this country for
hundreds and hundreds of years and a
change and because we're not gonna stop
on this until this changes and and once
again also all social issues are
interconnected right now
we are full force with with the black
lives matter and and and once again my
platform is for them but it's kind of
like the same thing I don't want to
compare because it's just another level
but the LGBT community also feels feels
this kind of injustice as and Prejudice
and mm-hmm
I am III think we are now understanding
of the power of minorities getting
together because at the end of the day
we
being kind of the same things and even
though you know the black community has
been struggling the way they effort for
hundreds of years we're in we're in this
together let's let's join forces and
that's let's talk about what what needs
to change I'm feeling it
I'm really excited I am the the rage the
anger when I see all those videos of all
these victims is is is making a
difference not only for me for my kids
and that's that's we're winning yeah
yeah and then when you know when it's
it's time for play when it's time to to
hear that what will we expect from play
well even though I could say the album
is is done the creative process is not
over we it's not oh it's over we will we
will write music and and let's see what
happens but it's definitely gonna be up
to uplifting there is work in this album
that I'm releasing today there is one
song that is with me the rest are kind
of like that so that gives me the
license to in the next album maybe
present one ballot just one because
there is the rest is gonna be a party
that's what I want to do and and nothing
I just want to go back to my my culture
and and just bring bring it everywhere
that's awesome awesome hey thank you so
much for your time it was great chatting
video yeah all the books on the best